buck do you remember me your mom's name
was Sarah he used to wear newspapers in
your shoes you're a wanted man I don't
do that anymore all the people who think
you did are coming right now they're not
planning on taking you alive
captain well a great many people see you
as a hero there are some would prefer
the word vigilante you've operated with
unlimited power and no supervision
that's something the world can no longer
tolerate I know how much [ __ ] is here
stay out of this one please
you only make this worse you saying
you'll arrest me
will be consequences captain you seem a
little defensive has been a long day
if you can accept limitations we're no
better than bad guys that's not the last
so simply want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options just people that shoot at
you usually wind up shooting at me too
you know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do who fight
sorry Tommy you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend so was I
you
you